we have multiple lengths of time here
and there measured in minutes so what we
want to do is say well it's an
equivalent number of seconds and so the
first one is pretty straightforward one
minute is equal to 60 seconds this is by
definition a second is one sixtieth of a
minute but what about five minutes well
we could try to visualize that if one
minute so let's say that is one minute
if that is equal to 60 seconds then five
minutes let's just let's just make five
copies of this so it's one two minutes
three minutes three minutes four minutes
and then five minutes so you see that
five minutes would be five times 60
seconds and five times 60 is 300 so here
you have so this is going to be five
times 60 which is equal to 300 300
seconds so what about 10 minutes well
same idea 10 times 60 is 600 seconds and
what about 60 minutes well 60 minutes or
60 seconds per minute times 60 minutes
is equal to 3600 seconds so that's
interesting let's take things a little
bit further let's convert between hours
between hours minutes minutes and
seconds so let's say that we have let's
say let's start off with something
that's a little bit more straightforward
let's say that we have one hour well we
know by definition one hour is equal to
60 minutes and how many seconds is 60
minutes equal to well we just figure
that out 60 minutes times 60 seconds per
minute gets us to 3,600 3,600 seconds
3,600 seconds now what about two hours
what about two hours well it'd be the
same exact idea 60 minutes per hour if I
have two hours it's going to be
two times sixty two hours times 60
minutes per hour gets us to 120
well how many seconds is that going to
be well there's a couple of ways you
could think about it you could take 120
minutes times 60 seconds per minute or
you could say 2 hours times 3,600
seconds per hour so let's do it that way
so 2 hours times 3,600 seconds per hour
gets us to 7,200 seconds now what if we
were to say 10 hours 10 hours well once
again 10 times 60 10 hours times 60
minutes per hour would get us to 600
minutes and if we want to think in terms
of seconds 10 hours times 3,600 minutes
per 10 hours times 3,600 seconds per
hour gets us to well it's going to be
3,600 tens which would be 36 36 thousand
or 10 times 3,600 or 10 times 3,600